um the drill [__] is so like it feels
like from like a guy who lives in L.A
because I got out there we hung out with
a we hung out with Dusty we hung out
with yeah uh who else you know a bunch
of those guys yeah
um but obviously the the rep is is a
very violent divisive genre of music
right
um do you have you ever got wrapped up
in any of the [__] just because I'm
sure you gotta be kind of play friends
with everybody right of course is it
because and do you think it's a lot a
lot of it's overstated
um there well I got a few opinions on
that well like the one thing I got
caught up in was like when you know
there was like a point where I was like
all right like y'all doing too much like
dissing on my show like I'm not trying
to do all this right right so I I like
made a statement where
um that I caught a lot of flack for like
from people this like a year ago where I
was like look I think I remember that
you said like no more just anybody no
more name dropping right and if you do
name drop it's gonna get x'd out right
because I'm not trying to do I want to
add to that right I don't I'm not trying
to add to that I'm not trying to politic
with that and I but I still want to
support y'all because I believe in a lot
of them right you feel me and I caught a
lot of flack for that but over time like
you know like anything you just write
out the wave and it's cool you know what
I'm saying like nobody really is like is
like upset by that anymore they're like
oh why can't I do that why guys I'm like
I'm not gonna let you use my platform as
a way to like go at y'all right right
there's other platforms that you could
go do that on go do that on that
platform this is like you know if you
want to create like the corner store
like the perfect Cornerstone hip-hop
platform like I don't want it to be
known for that right
um so like that part but I feel like you
know when it comes to like the music
itself is like these kids like this is
what they really live in and I feel like
me like I think Rob Markman had also
said on like rotation uh Roundtable to
show that I do on Amazon he was like
look man he's like if you really
listening to a lot of like you know
gangster rap lyrics from like 90s early
2000s like if you listen to like the
locks like they they say in some of the
same [__] that these kids are saying
they just saying it differently like
definitely now it's more like
um
I feel like it's more detailed for sure
but also it's not that far from what
we've already gotten in the past you
feel me and again like these kids like
this is their real life situations and
that's and you know it just feels more
like you said not only the detail aspect
of it but we also like back then we
didn't have social media so like
[__] were going live on
people's blocks and like it just feels
like now it's like man these guys are
really doing some [__] on the internet
then going and rapping about it and then
getting arrested for it and then getting
sentenced like no it's definitely dumb
like like it's definitely dumb how they
put everything on the internet right
I've been thinking about like if the
internet was around back then like it'd
be it'd be a wild place because then you
had hip-hop police back then and I'm
sure there's hip-hop police now but back
then it was like there was like a whole
task force like right obviously like I
was even just watching this video on the
way here it was like 50 Cent I forgot
what BET Awards it was but it was like
you know they're like 50 was a wild boy
like he didn't wrap the whole first
verse of his song walked around the
arena waiting to see if if any of his
like Ops or whoever would do something
and like you know and they're like and
what was the caption was like oh the BT
Awards need to start bringing rappers
back to the BET Awards who beef with
each other you know what I'm saying no
and I was like first of all terrible
idea terrible idea but at the same time
it's like but I think about like okay
that was 50 back then now and that's
without the internet so imagine if like
I would have been all over academics and
shade room and right so it's like it's
not that much you know when people
criticize or you know the last
generation criticizes this generation
for what they do I think it's just like
you gotta look in the mirror and be like
look if social media was around when you
guys were outside doing what y'all was
doing it's like it it wouldn't really be
that different we're all human at the
end of the day like I wouldn't be
surprised if back then you would see
like somebody on IG live talking oh ah
like oh no no if the internet was not
around so it's like it's different bro
it's like [__] when 50 first came out
I'm not even sure Myspace was popping
like that definitely not definitely not
but it's like yeah it's different
different world everything like
everything's online and then also the
pressure of like having a I look like a
[__] because you're on the internet
comes into people reacting maybe if they
wouldn't have reacted had they not
realized that the whole world will see
how they would react you know what I'm
saying right but would I be telling them
too I'd be like look like sometimes like
with the music that y'all make is like
you have to remember that the music that
you make like it's not just people and
if we're talking strictly from a New
York drill perspective it's like it's
not even just like the music people in
New York aren't just seeing this like
people all around the country seeing
this and like that affects your money at
the end of the day too because someone
from you know you're talking from like a
West Coast perspective if you hear them
talking crazy just an X Y and Z is like
and you're a promoter or you're a show
book or whatever your Live Nation it's
like I don't know if I want to book
these well even like the rolling loud
[__] like guys was getting like they
were getting banned from right Ron soon
uh I think Dougie B2 and like it's like
I'm like some of this stuff and Ronson
didn't I don't know why they did that
Toronto but like all this stuff can
affect your money at the end of your
longevity so like let's say you have
like the biggest diss record in the
world great but like
if how but like are you worth a
liability for me to book you yeah what
at what cost like like it got you lit
amazing congratulations I think that
that's great for you but like at what
cost is at what cost does it then affect
the rest of your money now because now
people for the rest of time will be like
I don't know because they're a liability
because you know I don't want him coming
to LA and then right the people that
they're talking about move to LA too and
then now they the people they talking
about trying to get somebody to come
through I mean like if you think about
the nationally biggest people
obviously pop smoke rest in peace rest
in peace pop but pivoted into and I
don't even he didn't even get to see the
success of his pivot sonically
um
504 and you know doing a record with
Alicia and like not necessarily leaning
on that [__] and then even like I mean
nice spice is rapping over drill [__]
you know what I'm saying like yeah she's
a pop star it's kind of crazy it's like
really crazy yeah I spice is the closest
thing that I've ever seen that if
someone said that industry plans for a
real which they're not I don't believe
that I don't believe that either yeah
that's not a real thing but if there was
like some like internet rap conspiracy
that I spice was an industry plan I'd be
like I understand why you think that
right because it is just like
it's crazy has she done an interview
besides you yeah oh yeah yeah she's like
breakfast club or anything she she
hasn't done right she did Ebro on Apple
on Apple one but she hasn't been like
like the traditional Hot 97 she did hot
she did oh yeah she didn't want it out
but it wasn't like super and he doesn't
do a lot of interviews I noticed that
too he's probably smart not to
overexpose yourself yeah I think like
you know you know what you were saying
about like the the with pop like first
of all like the fact that pop is still
probably the most streamed artist in New
York in terms of younger artists bro in
L.A this [__] non-stop every
single power rotation for like two years
straight I'm talking about like what you
know about love is still like a sub
power in La yeah it's crazy like it and
it's it sucks because he didn't get to
see yeah you know the fruits of his
labor 100 you know like I feel like
part two of the uh what was the EP that
he put out was it the um before he died
it was the oh um
that was the last piece of work I think
yeah before he passed literally like two
weeks yeah and then this [__] album
drops and it's like just hit record
after hit record and it's like and it's
crazy because this is like the album
that dropped probably that was I don't
know I was I they did something called
where they played a project I don't know
if they said it was 60 done before he
passed away or something like that but
like you imagine it's like okay what if
you actually finished still around and
he was here to finish these records and
had the features on it that he wanted
you know not saying that they put all
those features on there because I think
50 did a great job of like executive
producing and same because like yeah
this the because the last album was cool
but it was definitely you're like oh
this this was like
super unfinished stuff that they just
pulled together and there were so many
random features and [__] and yeah one of
my one of my man's produced one of the
songs on on on that on on that project
and then they switched they like
switched the beat on him see like that
kind of shit's like you know or like um
they had two songs on there the one with
busy Banks and the one with Ross wish
those were songs that were 100 finished
before he passed away 100 finished and
they changed him no no they let him kept
him but you could tell like when you
listen to the project you can kind of
tell what records were there before he
passed away versus what was kind of like
kind of Frankenstein together after the
fact and like that sucks to me like and
I heard stories like his friends versus
getting taken away from him and stuff
like that like and I I don't like [__]
like that because I'm like look like he
was trying to put his P like pop was
always about putting his people like if
you watch all these interviews with him
especially the Angie interview he talked
about Chef he talked about sleepy I
think he talked about busy in there he
talked about Ross wish trying to think
well but like he was always about
putting like people who he [__] with
on so like I think that that's just
unfortunate that we got to a point where
it's like okay now we're just gonna
we're gonna throw this pop verse here
you know what I'm saying like I know
there's one on nigo's album I don't know
where that came from like right right I
think about things like that and that
[__] kind of sucks Tiger's got hella
versus
oh Pop versus I think he's got one or
two out I'm like Tyga he got the
sunshine one the one with him sunshine I
feel like there was another one though
or am I tripping no I'm thinking Tyga
and him had a record together on oh yeah
yeah I liked West Coast [__] that was a
good school yeah but yeah like you think
about like I don't know I don't know if
Sunshine was done before pop passed away
or not I'm not gonna I don't know the
story behind that record but like if it
was Frankenstein together it's like damn
like they did a good job they did a good
job Frank is signing that one together
but it was kind of sad yeah